ja ich habe junge schau dir den modulen
und das ist der clou ist der knüller
halte deshalb nun schriftzug die luft
ausgeht und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft ich bin heute
publik
aber nicht alleine sondern mit priester
weniger und bevor wir los laufen leute
die heutige challenge beispiel change
mit wenig wird die folge sein wg meint
ressource pakete und sehen hier ruby
kraft 128 ein paar von euch wissen schon
was bedeutet für alle anderen halte ich
fest
willy mattes auch rein ich hab's drin
und versteht das langsam eine neue
texturen pack es gibt nur waffen und
rüstung und alles andere hat einfach
keinen texturen sicher dass ich meinen
namen drauf aber ja die kiste partikel
die kämpfe und dadurch findest du die
kiste die füße partikel und ich weiß
weiß auch so grob wo die kisten sind
denn du kennst sie jedes mitglied muss
ich hier weiter ab so dass eine leiter
man muss immer schauen wo jeder denkt
ich ja du musst echt schon so nah dran
ist bei ich ich ich laufe das hat echt
so aus dem gedächtnis raus ab jetzt voll
die probleme einfach weil ich eure
ganzen rudel nicht kennen ok teilweise
denk ich mir auch so herr moment arbeite
ich habe jetzt das zweite modul ich
kannte das ich kenne das spring ich
vollauf na ja aber ich hab's gar nicht
erkannt einfach ja ich habe leute da
geht teilweise sogar eine maus richtig
witzig sind auch türen warte hier ist es
hier ist es wie lange wird aber ich
erkenne das motto jetzt sollte ich das
schaffen was ich da was das was ist das
für leute die ihr kennt sich ja gar
nicht alles ist das als ob universe das
erkennt man ja gar nicht alles was den
vorteil hat man sieht glas gut weil
einfach nur ein schritt in die luft
fliegt ob beim sprung ist runtergefallen
venier der alten ist oberbauleiter
schwede man wie lange ich gebraucht um
zu chip zu blicken welches modul das
hier ist es dass mit den weins leute wo
man sich so hoch springen und flamme und
schlenkert eishockey checkpoint okay das
kann man natürlich auch ja relativ gut
bekannt aber das ist schon ist schon
sehr tricky hier so ganz ohne texture
pack ich habe ihn eigentlich ja der
stellt der shader forciert
überraschenderweise doch der star wurde
in die presche mittelfinger error
so nach dem motto ich will das nicht
sehen was mit ph ist echt so war ich
verweigere meine mitarbeit bei so einem
behinderten texture pack
hundertprozentig die kiste bei dem
nächsten
ich hab's welche module bist du ich
glaube 5 ich bin auch dass das nach
diesem saturn das war meine jackmann
welches ist das auch jetzt kann ich
erkennen es leute die da hinten ist die
gäste geht hier ja wohl die kisten sie
nur so komisch aus die komik des
formates im shaker sanchez und dann just
also ein dreiviertel blog wenn er noch
mal ein snap darüber nicht richtig wenn
hart modul kommt und dann steht halt
eiskalt seitensprünge einfach auf den
hacken und ich kenne das nicht mehr so
was kommt da bin ich ja du hast recht
das recht da bin ich ja mal ein eis und
jetzt hier bin wir durch so bist du ich
häng gerade hätte man da oben hoch ist
und die hamburger steht der begriff zu
klettern
ohne witz und jetzt bin ich wieder hier
unten auch hier ist die leider ach so
ich habe ernsthafte probleme einfach
durch den bruder zu kommen und ich kann
mich eigentlich schon gut außerdem
modulen oder slave wird steht leider
mein gesicht war ich sehe gar nix was
ist das 800 alles klar
als ob man was ist das modul 6 ist ja so
random yaman alten lover und aha dieser
erste strände mal bitte lass mich dass
ja berufsoptimist aber das kenne ich das
nicht vom ersatz der ersten module alles
alles klar ich brauche meine leute ist
es gar nichts mehr ist einfach so ein
texter person blocking sich bitte auf
hin zu brennen bitte bitte bitte gott
mann ich will nie wieder in meinem leben
in diesem jahr der ableitung leichter
springe leiter sprung ist im fussball
gott oh gott oh gott leute könnt ihr
kurz mit dem saugen warten mit
mitbewohnern jetzt musst du nachher
sorgen hat ja ich muss sowieso sorgen
eigentlich hatte leider leider hier ist
leider leider leider lag es ist so
random an
man ist so schwer modul 7 bei der leiter
springen man kennt sich kenne ich
einfach nur aus es ist so so
gottverdammte random an
man finde bin ich überhaupt ich weiß
nicht wie das damals war bis vor das ist
hatte haye oder sich das modul acht es
war wieder wie sie das ist das hat
nichts mit leuten zu tun dass ich voll
simpel gehalten
normalerweise ist doch hier irgendwo
leder oder und damit 6 und wo bist du ja
ja da gibt es an der wo bist du gerade
bist du bei diesem gebäude hoch
gesprungen ich hänge an der wand der
jetzt gerade was die länder da also ich
bin von der ebene hatte ach da drüben
ist die länder laut muss kann man schon
zurücktreten
und jetzt alles klar wo man junge leute
spielt es unbedingt mal nach ist es sehr
sehr sehr schwierig irgendwie richtig
lächerlich
du bist einfach ist das
das produkt kann ich sogar das kann ich
ja man kann man kann man kann man ja
das ist relativ easy das danach
eigentlich auch volk darüber kann sich
hin
die leute ich hab ich habe das problem
ist ich anhabe noch nicht kennen ich
habe einfach gerade die habe das modul
verwechselt ich dass mir das andere
man muss ich weiß nur gott oh gott nein
okay da nichts
das hat eben schon mal wo bist du bist
bei auch bei dem modul 8
ich bin acht jacobi ist beim modul 8
sind diese drei fliegenden insel na ja
da bin ich bei der zweiten jetzt alles
gleich springt rüber und fotoapparate
hier ist es ja du musst rechtlich immer
rechts muss erst mal hin
auf der findling kiste gefunden beste
tür vor der kiste steht auch im blut tnt
und enchantment airways und es ist alles
mega mega sorry mein gott auch vor der
kiste
ich sehe du bist eben hier guck mal wie
gesetz 49 leute schaut euch mal die tür
an die tür ist einfach ein schriftzug
ziert der schriftzug bewegt sich einfach
mit dem sound ja das ist vollkommener
hätte ich die kiste dich auf machen und
euch den sound gehörten dann leute dass
eine tür
er ist es so ich glaub ich hab jetzt
aber für dieses modell
ja ich bin auch gerade und ja ich habe
ja auch dort junge schau dir modul
erneuern das ist der lohn ein
der knüller alter das ist einfach ein
schriftzug boden trap door das ist
richtig schwer machen springen muss ja
bei der ballett stepptanz macht ihr denn
trikot ist nicht sehen muss
vor beinahe etwas wie lange gedrückt
haben das war am ende so schwer
du hattest einfach nur die schriftzüge
in der luft die umgebung hier sitze
wackeln runter wie eine geisterstadt
einfach nur jana ist es so ausgeschaut
diesem papier statt nur dass sie ohne
zusätzliche das papier das in der stadt
halt nicht keine menschen sind sondern
hat einfach keinen texturen
ich weiß nicht mal welche das wäre wenn
man mich fragen villa la la la la
ist das bitter aber ich weiß ganz viel
heißt aber die hatten wir auch in
unserem deathmatch er mit dem einem
crosstrainer gespielt haben dann hast du
dich noch dann ist das mirage oder auch
keine aviv als wir am ende gegen alle
kämpfen weiß ich muss mich auf jeden
fall in brand setzten
ich hab gar nichts gesehen ist alles
weiß twitter
ich werde jetzt abgeschlachtet einfach
fast alle details das war hier drin wo
gallen dir und ich komm nicht so recht
das überfordert mich so krass alter
schwede
warum habe ich zu wenig leben auf einmal
niemanden gebe es drei gegner gesehen
zweimal bin ich im zug gestorben weil
alles klar okay es mit mega gut darum
gelaufen ich jetzt auch einmal umgelegt
hier ist euer blog wie das aussieht
einfach ja das sieht mega venom aus ich
hab' ich habe die waffen fahrzeuge
danke danke danke danke ihr okay das ist
halt leicht nein ich glaube ich habe
angst das wird nämlich sehr gefährlich
jetzt gleich wenn dann musste ich meinen
ersten tod sterben dieser runde wohl
noch dein leben was es gibt trotzdem
aber richtig übel timo down mega viel
kann ich meine stärken könnte sich dem
leben und ich hab ihm abgestaubt aber
ich hab dann tnt und einen stick aber
jetzt welche die timo timo must be
tricks aus timo s p tags aus
nein als ob mein antivirus jetzt auch
pop als ob genau diesem moment wird noch
ein leben ich hasse dieses programm ich
schwöre ich dir dich und deine ganzen da
ich jage deine entwickler und
deinstalliert auch ihre leben alte post
erhält man jetzt ich gegen timo jeder
noch ein leben als den vielleicht auch
nicht mehr erlaubt diese combo ist
gibt's ja nicht ich glaube doch was ist
es dann hätte es gibt echt nicht das
alter timo ist bist du ganz entschied
oder als manager oder so leute don't try
this at home ganz ehrlich erspart euch
selbst die qual über diesen text effekt
zu spielen ich bin wir haben auch uns
genommen wenig unten verlinkt übrigens
wie immer wir sehen uns morgen wieder
mit neuen videos
bis dann